suite louis betinho chercheur au centre
géode géopolitique de la data ce faire
spécialiste des couches basses et
intermédiaires du cyberespace dans les
conflits territoriaux en ukraine et en
géorgie
bonjour merci d'être avec nous lorsque
vladimir poutine déclare que quiconque
entend se mettre sur notre chemin doit
savoir que la réaction russe la réponse
russe aura des conséquences jamais vu
dans son histoire ça veut dire quoi est
ce une menace nucléaire ou une menace
nouvelle d'une cyberattaque d'une
ampleur jamais inégalé
bonjour oui je pense qu'effectivement la
menace à peine voilée d'abord celle du
nucléaire il qu'on peut évidemment se
poser la question
d'éventuelles cyber attaques le rien ne
permet d'affirmer une telle qu'on
précisions sur la pensée des lumières
poutine à ce moment là en revanche il
est vrai que l'historique des de la
pratique des cyber attaques par des
services russes et par des acteurs
russes non étatiques me permettre se
poser la question directement et les
pays occidentaux est ce qu'ils sont
prêts à faire face à des cyberattaques
venant de la russie
il est toujours difficile là aussi de
savoir exactement de quelle manière on
peut se préparer à ce genre de
cyberattaques évidemment
en matière de création de cyberattaques
l'imagination et la seule limite ce
qu'on a vu au dans des dernières années
et dans les derniers jours ça a
effectivement en tout cas on prend le
cren c'est effectivement que il y aura
toujours une faille une porte ouverte
quelque part qui permettra
une entrée d'éventuels hacker est la
dernière en date évidemment c'est
solarwinds qui a été effectué en donner
le bain et qui qui qui s'est déroulé sur
plusieurs mois et qui n'a été détectée
qu'au bout de 3 9 août 10 mois et qui a
permis
une pénétration très importantes dans
les systèmes gouvernementaux américains
et est ce qu'il ya une supériorité
technologique de la russie pour mener de
telles attaques ou pas
je pense pas qu'on puisse parler de
supériorité technologique il ya en
revanche une certaine culture de la
cyber offensive à la fois par les
services de l'état
donc on connaît un peu les services
militaires et du renseignement extérieur
il ya aussi une culture des acteurs non
étatiques qui sont relativement présent
et qui sont toujours aussi difficiles à
identifier en tout cas de manière
formelle conséquent en occident il est
souvent compliqué de faire ce qu'on
appelle l'attribution de cyberattaques
c'est à dire d'identifier formellement
un acteur derrière une attaque mais il
est vrai que on a une massification de
ce genre de pratique depuis quelques
années et quel pourrait être l'impact
d'une cyberattaque là actuellement en
ukraine
ben ça c'est toujours à quelque chose
d'assez difficile à savoir il est sûr
que le fait qu'il y ait eu des masses de
cyber attaques depuis quelques semaines
et une escalade clairement de ces cyber
attaques envers des sites
gouvernementaux
et des systèmes gouvernementaux
ukrainien indique quand même une
certaine faiblesse de l'ukraine quel
impact ça pourrait avoir dans le cadre
d'une coopération entière c'est-à-dire
le patron cinétique qui se passe dans le
champ opérationnel classique c'est assez
difficile à savoir c'est peut arriver
que d'une coordination très ferme entre
d'une part des cyber attaques qui sont
nés
consiste à une augmentation du chantier
rationnelle et une attaque cinétique
pour l'instant il est assez difficile de
savoir ce qui pourrait se passer on peut
imaginer certains scénarios qui seraient
des déconnexions d'internet dans
certaines zones par exemple à kiev où
effectivement les russes se rapproche
dans le cas d'une attaque sur des
infrastructures internet par exemple il
pourrait y avoir une perte de connexion
d'accès à internet ce qui permet de le
sommer évidemment un certain chaos on
peut évidemment penser à des appuis
cyberattaques qui ont déjà eu lieu
contre le réseau électrique ukrainiens
par exemple en 2016 où il y avait eu des
coupures dans la ville de kiev où en
2015 dans une autre ville de l'ouest
ukrainien tout ça sont des possibles est
évidemment là encore d'imagination dans
que là la seule limite qu'on puisse
avoir il ya une autre guerre qui est
celle de l'information comment cette
guerre était elle menée par les russes
actuellement
informationnel ou disons d information
sont un sou sur plusieurs tableaux il ya
d'un côté on pourrait parler d'une
division entre l'audience internationale
les l'audience nationale au niveau
interne pour la russie ce qui est ce qui
apparaît de plus en plus évident c'est
que les russes dont des informations
très parcellaires et très partiales sur
ce qui se passe on parle pour l'instant
uniquement dans les médias russes d'une
intervention dans le don de basse alors
que évidemment on sait que
l'intervention est à l'échelle du pays
entier à l'international il ya eu une
grande opération de désinformation
beaucoup d'opérations de ce qu'on
appelle des faux drapeau c'est à dire
des opérations créé de toutes pièces
dans le bond de basse pour faire croire
à une des interventions en tout cas des
opérations ukrainienne il ya eu tous les
discours de vladimir poutine qui sont
très forts qui sont d'ailleurs inédit
sur la dénazification de l'ukraine qui
reprennent des dd narratif qu'on a vu
depuis 2014 sur l'idée d'un coup d'état
fasciste à kiev mené par la cia ou par
des forces d'extrême droite ukrainienne
et cette idée de devenir lutter contre
des
fascistes ou des nazis on fait partie de
tout un très grand message à un très
grand narratif déployés par la russie
depuis huit ans qui sont repris depuis
peu de manière beaucoup plus massive
et qui sont répétés à l'envi par les
médias internationaux en russie on a
aussi vu des campagnes sur les réseaux
sociaux
qui reprennent là aussi des stratégies
qu'on a déjà vu dans les années
précédentes qui consiste à troubler le
message et à prolonger quand même le
message du gouvernement russe et vous
m'avez vu aussi
émané des
des républiques populaires de windscale
genk les mêmes messages donc à une
coordination aussi entre les acteurs qui
semblent assez assez évidente et comment
sais tu comment se fait-il qu'elle n'est
pas contré par les occidentaux comment
se fait-il que cette guerre soit aussi
asymétrique au niveau de l'information
alors elle les contrées par les
occidentaux en partie c'est assez
compliqué de gérer la réception de la
formation par des populations entières
dans le monde occidental il ya eu des
hauts des mesures contre cela quand même
il ya eu l'allemagne qui a récemment
interdit les chaînes internationales
russes à l'instant ou en tout cas depuis
hier on voit de plus en plus les choses
arriver dans ce sens là la pologne a
également interdit des chaînes arte pas
des chaînes appartenant au groupe rte je
pense que c'est ce qu'on va voir de plus
en plus aussi et al'inverse il peut être
de manière plus anecdotique on voit
aussi des démissions de plus en plus
c'est des journalistes de rtl qui ne
cautionne absolument pas le
déblaiement sont propagées par par
l'état russe
il s'agit de contrer pour les
occidentaux de contrer la propagande
russe est ce que vous diriez que les
systèmes informatiques étatiques et
économiques des états occidentaux ont
des moyens de sécurité suffisant
actuellement
alors là aussi c'est très difficile on
est sur du ressort du pas très
clairement du secret défense rien ne
permet de penser que
ni qu'ils sont prêts ni qu'ils ne sont
pas prêts là on sort quand même des
compétences du chercheur puisque on en
vient aux domaines stratégiques
de toute évidence de ce qu'on a vu des
cyber attaques précédentes comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure il est
toujours possible évidemment qu'il y ait
des attaques massives on a vu que
récemment et le maquereau a demandé à ce
que tous les systèmes tous
les organes de défense aussi bien de
cyber souhait sur le qui vive et soient
en état d' alerte maximale donc ça
montre quand même une certaine
inquiétude des gouvernements occidentaux
et on verra évidemment si la russie
s'engagent sur ce sur ce domaine là pour
l'instant rien ne permet de dire pardon
merci beaucoup lui betinho pour votre
décryptage et merci